hey everyone welcome to Simply learns
YouTube channel today we will learn
about the top Excel productivity hacks
that said if these are the type of
videos you'd like to watch then hit that
like And subscribe buttons and the bell
icon to get notified just for your quick
info if you want to upscale yourself
master business analytics skills and
landar your dream job or grow your
career then you must EXP CL simply
learns gooh of various business
analytics programs simply learn offers
postgraduate programs from P University
in collaboration with Amazon Google and
Microsoft through this program you will
gain knowledge and V expertise in skills
like prescriptive and Predictive
Analytics regression classification and
over a dozen others that's not all you
also get the opportunity to work on
multiple projects and learn from
industry experts in Top Tire product
companies and academic from top
universities after completing these
courses thousands of Learners have
transitioned into a business analytics
role as a fresher or moved onto a higher
paying job profile if you are passionate
about making your career in this field
then make sure to check out the link in
the pin comment and description box
below to find out a business analytics
program that fits your experience and
areas of Interest now without further
delay let's get started with our
onepoint agenda that is Exel
productivity hacks so in this particular
productivity hacks tutorial we will find
out some hacks and shortcuts that will
ease up your day-to-day life with Excel
now without further delay let's get
started and open a spreadsheet with some
data on it so right now we are on the
data set so this is particular data set
is based on employee data and you can
already see we have a lot of data and uh
uh if let's say you wanted to scroll
down to find out a particular employee
and uh you can see I have the employe ID
name designation Department salary date
of birth date of joining these are not
moving those are sment right if you want
to do that you can do that using the
freeze option in the data set so you can
do that by going to
view select the column and click on
freeze paines you can freeze the first
row or the First Column let's say we
want to freeze both now your First
Column and first row ien
Frozen select that data
first PR so select the first column and
first row and then Pras them and there
you go you got them FR Frozen right and
you can also unfreeze them and in this
particular situation if you just want to
freeze the row because we don't have
much of the columns you can just freeze
the first row and whenever you scroll
down that particular row or the column
header has been frozen now if you want
to navigate all the way to the bottom
using the arrow keys it might take a
long while but there is a shortcut key
which is control down arrow which will
automatically take you to the bottommost
cell and control Arrow up to reach the
first cell control Arrow right to reach
the last cell on the right side and left
to reach the first cell and in case if
you wanted to select the entire column
then you can use the shortcut control
shift down arrow key to do that right
and uh and after that let's also take a
look at some of the more shortcuts
available or productivity hacks that are
more available if you want to select the
entire table you can you know click on
this particular icon which is over here
which will select the entire cells in
this particular table and if you want to
select the entire table which has the
data then you can just click anywhere in
the table control a and the table got
selected and apart from that if you want
to select a particular selection of
cells then you can navigate using the
shift key and holding the shift key you
can just make use of the arrow keys to
select that particular set of data sets
and now moving ahead let's say there is
a new entry to your data set someone
joined here and you are adding the data
to that particular employee
and all right and now if you want to add
the designation see the designation is
something which is always repeating
right so you might have have to select a
few options out of the available options
right inside such scenarios you might
want to have a data validation type of
shortcut right so let's say the data
validation has not been created for your
particular dat set right so uh in this
particular selection you don't have the
data validation options if you see it's
not there but if you want that option
anyway then you can use the shortcut key
combination that is alt down arrow key
which will automatically give you the
present options in your data set and you
can select
it same alt down AR key and the
department could be anything which you
wanted him or her to put it so it
support and you can also decide the
salary that you have over
here and the current date of joining or
date of birth his date of birth you can
let's say he was born in this part the
same date date of birth and the date of
joining is anything which is let's say
this particular employee
joined on the same
T the prev there you go now let's move
on to the next set of shortcuts now
let's say you wanted to select a
particular row right now let's say I
wanted to select the r number 16 then
you have a shortcut for that as well
click on that particular cell anywhere
in I mean anywhere in the room which you
wanted to select and shift right arrow
key
sorry not right it is shift space bar
and the entire row gets selected and now
let's say I wanted to select the column
now instead of shift use control and
space bar to select the entire column so
it is sh shift space to select the row
control space to select the colum now
that was a pretty decent hack why did we
do that because let's say you wanted to
add a new entry in between 10,27 and
10,28 in such scenarios control space
control shift plus to add a new row and
control minus to remove that all right
in the same way let's say you wanted to
add a new colum we know the shortcut to
select the entire column which is
control space now control shift plus to
add a new column control minus to delete
the existing columns right now moving
ahead now let's say you wanted to shift
this particular row to a you know top
position somewhere to uh in between five
and seven you can click on this row
number over here and hold the left Arrow
key right uh and that's when this
particular entire uh row gets selected
and then you can see a new type of
cursor over here just hold and drag it 2
and in between fth and seven replace it
or you can even you can replace it or
you can just uh cancel and you can just
move it so this is how it's done shift
space bar and you can see this over here
you can move it and you can have it in
between Sixth and E right so the those
are the two hacks if you want to remove
that particular existing you can you can
do the previous method if you want to
place it in bit wi then you can just
shift space and you use this particular
one and place it between some right and
moving ahead the next uh hack is let's
say uh you wanted uh let's say you're
par working with another employee or
your G and uh you wanted to leave a
comment for him right so there is a
shortcut key for that as well control
sorry not control it's the combination
of shift plus F2 which will okay fun
function F2 which will start up a new
comment with your name over there and
you can just tell
your please check it you
know can you please check
it right so it's it's a we right and it
will be highlighted whenever someone
holdes onto it it will give you the uh
comment let's contrl C and remove that
comment let's proceed now the next hack
is let's say for now we have 30 or 32
rows for now so it's not a big deal
let's say we have 10,000 rows and you
wanted to go to row number let's say 21
so we have the shortcut keys which is
control down AR which will take you all
the way to down control right which will
take you all the way to right but if you
wanted to go to any cell to win the
cells the end cells how to do it let's
say I wanted to go to uh d8 how can I do
it so let's get back to uh this
particular first cell now contrl G and
you can now add the reference set
d8 you can see the control went to d8
directly over here so that's another
short cut or another hack that you might
want to use in your day-to-day life now
proceeding ahead let's say try to add a
new column here control Shi plus
copy contr V let's say I want to add
another
one
right so let's say let's consider these
as the first names and you know Escape
so let's say these are the first names
and these are the last
names and I want to combine them both
right so it can be
done equals
concat have to press the function cell
one and the sent and you might want to
add a SPAC between ENT and
C2 there you go
now you can just control
e double click on them and this will be
added and uh now if you wanted to split
that it's really simple you can add
another column in between shortcut
control space control shift plus to add
a new
column you wanted to add the first name
and only if you press control e it will
fill all the first names here and contr
E it will fill all the second names over
here that is called the flash F in Excel
which could be a good uh way for you to
save time separating the first names and
the last names and you can also use
another technique which is text to
columns that is another technique to
split the first names and the second
names based on uh you know uh symbol
which is separating them it can be a
comma it can be a pipeline it can be
space or any special symbol so you can
use that as well okay let's go to the
sheet two and here uh let's remove these
columns now it's taking a little time
okay not not not a problem the previous
shap got crashed so let's delete these
columns
volums delete now uh let's say I want to
copy these values and add somewhere else
somewhere over here right so you can see
the numbers are not same here we have
11,900 and here we have 10,000 which is
the actual value which is present in
column C so what's happening here so if
you double click it you can find the
values are based on a formula so it is
giving me the value of this particular
input but not the final
so in such scenarios what can I do right
contrl z now I think you have already
copied the sets right now instead of
just pasting them using control V you
can use a combination of keys which
happens to be control shift V ver will
past the values only regardless of the
formula being used in the background so
this is another hack and um let's
proceed with a few more now let's
discuss the last one now we know that
this is the salary detail right now if
you want to format this in terms of
rupees or dollars you have a shortcut
just control press one right this will
open the formatting sales option go to
anyone which is currency you can you can
go to currency or you can go to custom
so for now by default based location is
giving me rup but if you want American
dollars you can also do that should be
somewhere here you can search for it
let's say dollar you have the Canadian
dollars over here I think that will do
and press okay and there you go yeah
have the doll symbol and with that we
have come to end of this session on the
most uh commonly used uh Excel
productivity hacks and if you have any
queries regarding any of the topics
covered in this session or if you want
us to cover a few more productivity hags
or if you want a cheat sheet which has
all the productivity hacks that we use
in our day-to-day data data analytics in
our team then you could let us know in
the comment section below and our of
experts we'll be more than happy to let
you know all the details in a short
period of time and with that thanks for
watching and stay tuned for more from
Simply learning staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here